this is one of the biggest stunts in
fast nine
the latest fast and furious movie it's a
four second shot they could have made
entirely out of cgi
but instead they spent eight months
planning the stunt with real vehicles
the fast crew broke down the shot into
two parts and built this track to carry
the car
through the window and into the back of
this truck
then they programmed two motion
controlled cameras to perfectly sync
and then stitched it all into one
continuous shot
this was just one of many over-the-top
stunts in f9
which were all done with as little cgi
as possible
we see cars every day so anytime you go
to a kind of a cg
option if you're just off by like a tiny
bit the brain knows is not
real and spoilers ahead for f9
car flips are a common stunt in the fast
franchise
but for f9 the production team needed to
take this move a step
further when letty uses a magnetized car
to latch onto an suv during the film's
climactic chase in tbilisi georgia
yeah that's right that's a car that
attaches to another car
and then flips without cgi to get this
to work
the team had to reconfigure letty's car
so it could tow the second vehicle and
then release it at the right moment
first stunt coordinator andy gill and
his team removed the trunk
then they replaced it with a steel cage
so the suv's wheel would lock into place
to make it look like the suv is being
sucked into the trunk by a magnet
the crew built a ramp behind leddy's car
so the suv could easily hop onto it
a weighted overhead cable system then
helped with the final backflip
when the suv hit the end of the line the
cables yanked it
backwards
now that the crew could attach and flip
one car from a moving vehicle
how about two that's what happens when
dom pulls two suvs to his magnetized car
before repelling them
one suv survives its jump the other suv
leaps in the air thanks to a hidden ramp
built by the stun
team and that suv is destroyed
when it hits this small car followed by
this parked van
and then that car was pinned down on a
big steel plate
in the ground so it wasn't gonna move to
stop the suv's momentum
the van also needed a wall inside
i just had effects build a steel wall
and here's your car
right here at the firewall all the way
up to the roof
and put kickers back so you can't get
through it then it blows through that
second car and gets halfway through and
hits
that steel plate and that's what turns
it over
cables just weren't enough for this
stump when a car is flipped over on its
side
while this elaborate flip could have
been completely cg
gill found a way to do it practically
the key for this scene was something
called a flipper
basically the car is placed on a giant
pad with two hydraulic arms that extend
and cause the pad to flip
up launching the car along with it and
that henchman you see here
didn't actually get hit by this car to
flip the car without hurting
anyone they shot the scene twice the
first shot had the performer standing on
the car
but there was no flip in the second they
flipped the car from the same position
but with no actor these two shots were
then merged together
in post-production
magnet charge stunts didn't just involve
other cars
for this moment it was all about kitchen
appliances
unlike the flipper move it was possible
to have extras in this shot
but that added another risk factor yeah
you don't want to be in front of one i
can tell you that
before placing any extras gil used
sandbags to see how safe
each mark was and location was
everything put a lot of time and effort
into picking the right store for that
had big windows the sidewalk was just
right we didn't have trees or
telephone poles in a way for them to
come out launching the appliances
involved first welding a tube into
each one that tube was then inserted
into
another tube filled with compressed air
once that air was released
the appliance would shoot out like a
cannonball
so as the car is coming up i would say
three two
one now and we videotape it all and i
put white marks on the ground so i know
exactly when i said one
where the car was and then where those
machines were coming out
by doing all the tests we knew that
there was a big brick wall between
windows it was gonna be tight it's gonna
be a lot of stuff coming out broken
glass and all that but they can hunker
down and
people in the shot just looks good
dodging washing machines is hard
but what about explosives
during the first big chase of f9 dom and
his brother jake try to outpace each
other on jungle roads filled with land
mines
filming on location with real explosives
meant dealing with unpredictable weather
and smoke-induced visibility issues
instead of using the overgrown
muddy jungle roads on location in
thailand the crew built their own roads
out of decomposed granite
a much more suitable material for racing
in the end
they only created about a half mile of
new roads but the camera crew
using helicopters drones and off-road
buggies
could make it feel much bigger on camera
so it's short sections that we'd use
over and over
and and we would film different
directions so it looks different the
crew had to consider
even the tiniest details to keep the
driver safe
to make sure fires didn't start near any
of the drivers the crew wet down the
mulch that flew up in the air with each
boom
and they welded steel plates under the
driver and passenger sides of each car
to provide an extra layer of protection
between the passengers and any of the 30
real mortars planted in the road the
stunt drivers
also limited their speeds to below 50
miles per hour
even though in the movie they're
supposed to be going at least 80. a lot
of times
we're not going as fast as you would
think in a chase
but it looks a lot faster because we're
usually in confined areas
where you really want to speed it up is
when you have big wide open areas
and there's not really anything relative
to your speed
so you could be doing 120 and it doesn't
look fast
to ensure that the main cars looked fast
other cars had to slow down
i will do wipes with cars that are only
going 10 miles an hour so you're going
by
really fast and the climax of this
sequence is
even more extreme
this is a moment when dom and letty jump
from one cliff to another
attached to land by just one rope even
for a
fast movie this was risky but the crew
managed to create the scene
practically with just a little help from
cgi they filmed in a quarry with a 60-70
foot drop off
to imitate the cliff's edge on that edge
they reconstructed
the end of the rickety wooden bridge as
well as a steep ramp
so the car really did jump we could jump
hit that post and then land
still on the road careful cam
replacement obscuring the quarry made it
look
much higher on screen the swing was cgi
but the swing and eventual landing still
needed to try to follow the rules of
physics
so gill first conducted a toy car test
for the swing and landing like he did
with many stunts in the film
here he tied one to a string and ran it
over a table
the toy car came off like that and fell
really nicely
for a while and as soon as that caught
what happened instead of just swinging
and
swinging like this it snapped it around
almost upside down this way and then
back and around
for the landing they used a real car
rigged to complex cable strategically
placed on the hood
and around the back wheels as the car
got closer to its mark
another cable attached to the nose
stopped the front of the car from going
any further the forward momentum then
swung the back around
hitting its mark perfectly
all of these stunts were extreme but
nothing compared to the extensive chase
involving what may be the franchise's
most
ambitious custom build yet this is the
armadillo
a 14 foot high 26 ton three section
armored monster this beast of a vehicle
had to navigate narrow streets while
doing everything from driving on its
back
to sliding down a huge cliff between
this and all the magnet stuns
it's no wonder the entire tbilisi chase
took nearly a year to bring to life
four of those months were dedicated to
custom building two versions of the
armadillo
one for driving it like a normal truck
another for making it drivable when it's
turned upside down
those trucks are really really heavy
as we found out instead of building new
roads they worked with what was already
there
first by carefully selecting the run-up
area
these are the portions of road where the
cars in a sequence can gather speed
before getting to the piece of road
they're filming on
because it was so massive the armadillo
needed a lot of room to get up to speed
and it also needed a run out area or
extra road after the shot ends so nobody
has to slam their brakes and kill the
momentum
even though the armadillo was fast
enough gill found that getting
right up close to it could make it look
even faster
because the armadillo is so heavily
armored the crew used all the tools they
had
in new and imaginative ways for example
they could make a dent thanks to the
flipper which was just off camera
launching cars
over here and the parked car seen at
these two angles were attached to cables
on the ground that
when cut loose could be pulled right
into the armadillo's path
because so many parts of these
impressive feats were done in camera
every little detail needed to be laid
out far in advance but it's the
experimentation
and commitment to practical effects that
make every flip and crash feel so
visceral
that's what has always set this
franchise apart from its humble
beginnings
i think that when you do things
practically when two elements interact
like it almost like defies
physics because you can't mathematically
predict it because there's so many
variables and there's something very
visceral about that that we connect to
i have my whole my toy cars all the time
and
justin's eyes light up every time i walk
in with him because he knows we're gonna
play